all right Brianna
Brianna uh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally
um I grew up in Miami Florida
um originally from Miami Florida I moved
to
um Fort Lauderdale when I was 13.
tell me about your family
growing up
um growing up
um
my dad used to be
in real estate and an accountant and my
mother
works well she worked I didn't know
where back then but she works in
bookkeeping
and my dad when I was three years old he
started doing cocaine
and then it escalated into crystal meth
and
um his whole personality changed she
started getting felonies on his record
and
um lost all the money he put alone on
the house that me and my brother and my
mom were living in and
it was really hard because
he ruined a lot
um
financially for my family
and I'm the eldest child in my family
and I kind of got the blame for what my
dad has done and it was really hard on
me
and he has
um stolen from
his relatives and
has ruined the family's reputation in
many ways
of his drug addiction
yes and he
he was abusive he was around prostitutes
all the time
and
um
when my brother was being picked up by
him when my mom and before mom and my
dad had a custody battle he bought a
convicted child molester in the car to
pick my little brother up when he was
like six years old
um
it it was rough
how far did you go in school
um I went I got my GED I actually when I
was around 18 years old I quit school
and I ended up getting my GED
um
when
I was younger I struggled with my mental
health issues and I didn't care about
school or anything
I have
BPD and I have schizophrenia
and
I was making terrible decisions
I partied a lot and didn't care about my
future
and I struggled with
um trauma from
being sexually abused and
I was going down a dark path
you're sexually abused with
when I was a child
and
it was
you know when I was when I got older
um
it affected me and
I started getting into toxic
relationships and
that were code that were codependent
and I started getting attachments and
abandonment issues from it
you're sexually abused by a family
member or yes
I was
you're diagnosed with uh
borderline personality disorder and
schizophrenia win
when I was
a routine I was diagnosed with
schizophrenia when I was staying in a
long-term
psychiatric unit
and
when I got older attorney just get so
effective
and I was diagnosed with BPD when I BPD
traits when I was around 16.
by my psychiatrist
I was recently diagnosed with cptsd
are there medications that you're on for
this yes I'm on Abilify right now
um
one of my long-term goals is to advocate
for mental health
and I want to stand up for people
who have been failed by the mental
health system
because Florida has a problem
um Florida has a problem
with the Florida Baker Act and I've been
Baker acted before
um it's basically where they put you in
a 72-hour hold and
um you're handcuffed by police police
officers and
you're put in the back of the police car
and you're put in there with mean staff
who treat you like an animal
and
there's an objection
that the mental health technicians
called Booty Juice
and basically it's where they hold
patients down and against their will
they inject them
and
there has been enormous amounts of abuse
in Mental Hospitals that hasn't been
talked about
in Florida it's a sedative
yes
it's a sedative
and unfortunately I I have friends who
who that happened to and
I I was
um emotionally abused by the staff
in the Mental Hospitals
and
it's like you're being punished for
needing help
it's it doesn't help you at all there's
no treatment plan afterwards
and I think something should be done
about it
and there is also a housing crisis in
Florida and
um if you're if you have a disability
and you're low income and you have a
lack of support
it's like you can't get low income
housing there's no Section 8 there's no
subsidized housing that even exists in
the state of Florida
so if you're low income
um mentally ill and you have no support
you're basically screwed
and this is something that I have been
stressed about lately because
I have schizoaffective disorder and
schizophrenia and BPD
and I have to work you know I work
part-time right now
and I go to college right now
and
um if something were to happen to me if
I were to
if an emergency happened and I had to
get hospitalized or something
I wouldn't be okay because I don't have
enough support
and I have to pay rent
it's been difficult
a little stressful
how old are you now I'm 23. 23. I just
turned 23 yesterday oh happy birthday
thank you
so yours your struggles with
your mental conditions they can they
continue even though you're on Abilify
yes um
I've heard voices
um calling me a pig
calling me degrading me and calling me
all kinds of names
like on a daily basis and they would
tell me they would criticize my work
performance while I'm at work and tell
me I'm doing a bad job
and they would make me feel very
insecure and there were voices that have
been
effect like you know I've been hearing
voices all day like that
and with Abilify it helps a little bit
but it doesn't completely make it go
away
and those voices have contributed to
an eating disorder because they have
degraded me non-stop all day and that's
all I was hearing
when you say the voices are degrading in
what way
they would call me names they would tell
me to kill myself they would
I would hear them loudly
and it would be non-stop all day on a
daily basis
and it would make me have episodes
um schizophrenic episodes where I would
yell back at them
what do you think
most people that don't have these
conditions
or aren't experienced with them what do
you think they don't understand
it's hard
you know I have to ignore them
I have to pretend that I don't hear them
and I have to and it's hard to live with
it on a daily basis like hearing
people talk to you that aren't really
there
um
it's a very tough condition to live with
when
and if you're in public and you're
hearing these things and you have a
mental breakdown or an episode what are
the police gonna think
that you're using drugs yeah
and I don't use drugs and there's a
reason I don't use drugs and it's
because of my father
and
I don't want to end up like you did
that's a good enough reason
yeah
especially with the mental condition
that drugs are not going to help
no they're not and I've seen what it's
done to my family it has destroyed a lot
of things for my family
and
I did get the blame for it
um
some hurtful things have been said to me
by my family because I either look like
my dad or I'm the eldest child in my
family which my dad was
I was kind of made into a scapegoat
and treated unfairly
because of my dad's actions
no you're only 23 but do you have any
big regrets in your life
yes I do
I regret some of the decisions I've made
due to
um
my BPD
when I was 12 years old I had a suicide
attempt
where I jumped off a six-story balcony
and
it's actually a miracle that I'm alive
today
here telling my story how do you survive
a six-story gym
I don't remember much of it but what I
do remember is that I did hesitate while
I was on the balcony but it was too late
and I fell
and I was 12 years old and I was very
alone
I felt like nobody loved or cared about
me and
I I attempted suicide and when I
when I jumped
or fell
um
I
I was on the floor and I I only remember
waking up in the hospital in the ICU
hooked up to tubes I had a feeding tube
and I had a breathing tube and I had to
do facial reconstruction surgery on my
face were there other injuries
yes
um
this was what happened to my arm my arm
was like this when I jumped
and there was muscle sticking out of it
and I was
um
my face my jaw was broken
um I had to get plastic surgery on my
entire face
and I had a trig
can you explain to the viewers who don't
really know much about borderline
personality disorder what would it
what it's like
it's
being emotionally dysregulated
um it's hard to control your emotions
and
um
it's being paranoid and untrusting of
other people
it's developing attachments
you develop attachments to people that
your whole world evolves around and it
even can become an obsession
and it's having a fear of abandonment
and I've been through some toxic
relationships where I was codependent or
I had a savior complex with people and
um
there were times where I got hurt
because I was so attached to this person
that was abusive
that I didn't
I couldn't let them go
I had emotionally and physically abusive
ex-boyfriends
and I stayed with them
it's
it's a very painful mental health
disorder to live with
yes a suicide attempt at 12 years old is
pretty extreme
yeah
um
I was in love with someone
and I don't and there's a term called
favorite person in the borderline
community
and favorite person is one specific
person who your whole world revolves
around and it can be an obsession
and
I had a favorite person
who
I was very attached to
and he ended up taking advantage of me
and
he was a very
bad person and he reminded me of my
childhood a little bit
um
he led me into a hotel
for my birthday
and he invited invited a bunch of guys
and
we
drunk alcohol
and we smoke weed and the weed turned
out to be laced
and he left and I ended up
being sexually violated in the hotel
in 2019
and
he scammed me
um he caused a lot of trauma in my life
he emotionally abused me he threatened
me
with my life
I've been through a lot of toxic
relationships
such as that one
and
I have a lot of friends and I had a very
close friend who was very like
ahead of close friend who I really loved
and cared about so much
and she was going through some similar
things that I was going through
and
she committed suicide last year
and um
it's like the mental health system has
failed her
it's failed me it's failed a lot of
people and I really want to make a
difference
I want to do right by her
I have a tattoo with a semicolon here
it's my middle name with the semicolon
for the eye
and the meaning of the semicolon
is for suicide prevention
and to
and that it it continues
what is your biggest fear at this point
in your life
I have a fear of failure
I feel fear of not making it
I'm having no support
those are those are normal fears though
you don't you don't have a fear of
ending up on a sixth story balcony again
no
um this happened I'm 23 right now this
happened when I was 12 years old
I I do have a little bit of a fear of
heights due to that incident
um
if I were to go in any high place I
would be a little scared yeah but just
just the the tendency to want to end
your life is
what I'm referring to
I solved harmed I used to cut a lot
and
I don't necessarily
um
have a fear of that happening again
because I know that I I won't
jump again
with the suicide attempts are common
with people with PPT
they're extremely common
and
um
it's very unfortunate my friend who
committed suicide last year had BPD
and I've had not just one but several
suicide attempts
and it's very important to spread
awareness
of BPD
the favorite person thing is a common
story with BPD as well
what is that all about it's like you you
pick one person that just becomes your
everything
you don't even
um
you don't pick them you don't
you don't pick them
but it just happens you just start
develop developing these strong feelings
for somebody
you start developing strong feelings for
someone that you can't get them out of
your head
um
you can't
let go of them it's very hard to do
are there any positive aspects to BPD
yes
um
there's empathy
these
um
there's creativity
you know
um
people with BPD are very capable of
loving people deeply and truly
and
a lot of people with bpdf empathy and a
lot of people with BPD are creative and
strong
beyond the trauma that they've
experienced
so he
you've intensely then
the rest of us yes
what emotions do you go through
typically
do you get depressed angry anxious
I get depressed I get irritable
um
I get anxious a lot
I get
I get happy I get manic sometimes
um
my
I had mood swings when I get mood swings
it's like
it goes through the course of a day
in 24 hours my my moods will change
between happy sad angry very quickly
rapidly
you're also schizophrenic is that
something that just came into your life
recently
um yes it came into my life recently as
in around two years ago yeah usually
it's early 20s
yeah it came around two years ago and I
don't know what caused it maybe it was
from the trauma and
um
maybe it was
from being homeless for six months when
I was 18 I
I stayed at a homeless shelter for six
months and I was also on the streets
which which is more of a a problem for
you is it BPD or the schizophrenia
um depending on schizophrenia has its
moments
so sometimes it's livable sometimes it's
culpable and ignorable
but when it becomes a problem it becomes
a big problem
so I have some good moments with
schizophrenia
and with BPD it's like something I I've
dealt with every single day
um
I'd say that
it's both because with schizophrenia
depends on how bad it gets
do you have times where you just wish
you were normal and didn't have these
conditions
yes
because I didn't ask for them
and it's not it's not fun to live with
your family that have similar conditions
my dad
is a drug addict and he had bipolar
disorder
and it turned into schizophrenia because
of the math
um
my
my mother had anxiety
my grandfather
had a bipolar
but nobody had BPD or schizophrenia
without any drugs
does it slow down your
your ability to take care of yourself
and keep your job and things like that
it makes it tough it makes it very
difficult
um
it makes my schizophrenia affected my
job performance because I would hear
voices at work
but I did my best to um ignore it
and just don't listen to it
my anxiety is very bad and
at first my BPD has affected my ability
to
do anything with my life I've I was
self-destructive I was partying and I
was doing stupid things and not thinking
about my future for a while
it's gotten much better now because now
I'm really focused on College and I'm
focused on
um
I'm focused on my job right now and
getting better
and doing good in my life
do you have friends
yeah
I have some friends
what would you say is your greatest
strength
my greatest strength
um
I'm very creative and artistic and I'm
empathetic
um I'm a good singer I'm a good writer
I'm very good at writing it's one of my
biggest strengths
um
and I'm artistically creative
I
really want to make a difference and
make changes to the mental health system
and advocate
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
most important lesson
some
um
keep trying be productive
distract yourself if you're depressed
and dwelling on the past and
um
unable to move forward
start distracting yourself don't think
about it
if you're grieving don't think about it
keep pursuing keep working on yourself
keep
like
doing things with your life
don't be unproductive
all right Brianna thank you so much for
sharing your story
thank you I wish you lots of luck with
your
career in uh
I hope you're schizophrenia and
borderline kind of stay
out of your out of your way
thank you
thank you very much